olá boa tarde a todos
meu nome é guilherme brammer a sul de
são paulo há 38 anos sempre fui família
amigos bastante inquieto sempre quis
saber da vida como as coisas eram feitas
e obviamente acabei caindo pra fazer
engenharia de materiais que na época da
primeira turma da faculdade onde estuda
aqui em são paulo é justamente para
entender como as coisas são feitas
e pra falar de empreendedorismo
eu acho honestamente aqui todo mundo
empreendedor
a gente já empreendedores e desde a
nossa origem onde decorre o primeiro e
acha o primeiro álbum que os outros
lepra conseguiram já está saindo na
frente está investindo na gente já tá
correndo
então acho que desde sempre empreendedor
a pessoa que trabalha numa grande
corporação a empreendedora teve que se
render à teve que gerenciar o fluxo de
caixa dela pra conseguir numa um bom
jeito na entrevista e por aí vai
então honestamente empreendedorismo
talento do ser humano ser humano é o
empreendedor by design vão dizer sinto
um design aqui mas é honestamente eu
acho que também o empreendorismo a gente
acha que não é e precisa de uma ignição
precisa de algum algum toque aquela
aquela ficção né entre o fórum ea
caixinha que faz aquela chama aparecer e
pra mim é o empreendedorismo era eu fiz
minha carreira toda indústria pesada
trabalhei em fábrica de embalagem
fábrica de fabricantes de aço fábrica de
papel fabricante de plástico e enfim
superou aquela coisa bem pesada bem
hardy e eu era aquele reclamam eu era
clicar no cafezinho que eu odeio fazer
que o faça e blá blá blá blá blá mas no
fundo eu era de fato é uma pessoa
apaixonada pelas coisas é como as coisas
eram feitas eu tive oportunidade de
conhecer muito indústria que era
fornecedor de matéria-prima toda desde
fábrica de chupeta até fábrica de sabão
em pó
então eu tiver de fato essa questão mas
o django um pouco o meu status cody ano
tá dentro de grandes corporações
eu tive uma ignição na minha foi
familiar a quem eu tive há uma questão
quando conheci minha esposa veio veio a
família ver o sogrão né eu sou grão já
vivia com uma com a doença é uma doença
perto e ele trouxe pra gente aquela
a questão de viver o dia não se sabe se
o amanhã vai ter o dia ele trouxe a
questão de finitude é pra mim é
obviamente para a família inteira mas
pra mim aquilo que chacoalhou demais e
fez com que eu começasse a viver e
repensar minha vida e vai querer fazer
coisas que realmente eu sou apaixonado
ou seja é de questionar o status quo de
como as coisas eram produzidas como as
coisas vão fazer eu vivia muito
desperdício o meu dia a dia eu era eu
era cada vez mais cobrado para vender
cada vez mais né esse é o indicador de
performance indicador de vida eu pude
será que eu vou querer fazer sem
obviamente que vem de importante
obviamente que consumir é importante mas
será que nessa loucura e produzido como
as coisas são produzidas desde a
revolução industrial será que é esse o
caminho e aí com essa questão é do meu
sogro do tipo ele vivendo ele toma
quimioterapia 6 da manhã às sete da
manhã já estava na rua para vender para
trabalhar é e trazendo isso queria comer
cada dia eu nunca queria repetir um
restaurante que queria viver as
experiências da vida e essa questão foi
que parra que a minha indignação porque
é assim que eu faço é obviamente que
empreender sozinho é impossível essa é
ninguém tem uma ideia genial foi falado
isso e eu confirmo plenamente ninguém
tem idéia completas nas idéias nascem
pela metade e depois é que vocês que
consegue construir com boas parcerias e
também queria viver sustentabilidade na
prática foi aí que começou minha minha
vida minha mudança de vida de empregado
de trabalhar em grandes corporações para
empreender montar um negócio só estudar
não sabe entender um pouco que estava
acontecendo no mundo é estudar um pouco
do conceito de sustentabilidade ou como
conferir o engenheiro fiz uma pós em
marketing e comecei a me especializar e
fui estudar para entender um pouco esse
mundo da sustentabilidade e comecei ver
alguns tive acesso algumas pesquisas e
comecei ver o impacto que um ser humano
vai gerar em sua vida todo mundo passar
por aqui todo mundo está aqui que vivem
mais de 75 anos em sua vida é vai
consumir a quantidade de produtos que
está na tela
obviamente que cerveja pra mim podia ser
muito mais cinco mil litros acho que é
pouco né
mas se for ver é uma loucura a forma
quem está consumindo e o que a gente
está consumindo e da maneira como a
gente consome como produz né a hoje por
exemplo já se já se anda 6 km para
conseguir água potável no planeta terra
já a média de do que a pessoa tem que
percorrer para ter acesso à água né
vamos gerar 40 toneladas de lixo cada um
aqui vai gerar 40 toneladas de lixo
enquanto viver no planeta até 75 anos
outra questão que vem que também me
assustou um pouco não comecei a estudar
é a velocidade com que a gente está
duplicando no planeta antigamente
demorar uns setecentos e cinquenta anos
pra gente duplicar hoje já está em 40 em
45 anos já dobra a população chegará a 9
bilhões logo mais é muita gente vivendo
no mesmo planeta ea urbanização
tive uma organização enorme hoje já são
51 por cento vivendo em 2025 70% vivem
em grandes cidades estão com um produção
do jeito que é produzido gente cada vez
mais densa em grandes cidades há
obviamente que vai gerar muito mais lixo
é uma equação óbvia porque acaba
consumindo nas nas grandes cidades
produtos industrializados
e foi aí que eu comecei a entender qual
o impacto disso né milhares hoje de
espécies
tô morrendo intoxicado pela má gestão de
resíduos no mundo
você tem aí também em porto nas pessoas
né países sub-desenvolvidos outros
países em desenvolvimento são é é um
foco de de tráfico de lixo né países que
não têm mais espaço aonde você destinar
os resíduos acabam exportando para
outros países e uma questão simplesmente
que não é lógica né a natureza demora
alguns milhões de anos para mudar a
matéria prima a gente com engenharia
transforma essa esses recursos naturais
desculpa e matéria prima ou seja madeira
virar papel bauxita-alumínio aí depois
mais um pouquinho um pouco mais para a
indústria se transforma em alguns dias
às vezes um pouco mais a gente embala e
enche esse produto vem desse produto
distribui a gente consome algumas horas
a gente conseguiu muita coisa hoje
alguns minutos a e aí depois a gente
joga fora porque nada está sendo
desenvolvido na está sendo produzido
propósito simplesmente é essa maneira
linear
de ver o planeta trazendo um pouco o
nosso país é o brasil é um país em
desenvolvimento a gente já tá também
urbanizando bastante e começa a gerar
impactos que países gente grande já que
vive há muito tempo é hoje são 8 bilhões
de reais dispensados em lixo que está
indo pra terror lixão clandestino e
temos aí o mundo vivendo mais de 500 mil
pessoas vivendo e trabalhando em lichuan
a é esse foi o ponto que eu comecei a
estudar e aprofundar e foi aí que eu
criei um negócio simplesmente para
questionar o que a gente chama de
economia linear onde você está e
recursos produz a gente consome joga
fora e aí acaba desperdiçando muita
coisa nesse nesse nesse lixo foi estudar
um pouco mais e se deparou com o
conceito de economia circular onde você
começa a desenvolver produtos que eles
sejam mais fáceis de reutilização depois
do da vida e até por que não transformar
o produto em serviço e não mais em
produto em si só eu vou trazer alguns
casos para vocês aqui então como é que é
na nossa opinião como é que a gente nova
é impossível não vá sozinho inovação é
um processo social o que está fazendo
aqui é inovar na minha opinião ninguém
tem uma idéia genial que na sozinha como
já comentei mas sim um processo de co
criação é um processo é 3d de
contribuição para criar uma ideia
completa é então alguns casos de
economia circular já começam pelo mundo
isso é parece que não mas rede de pesca
é um grande fator de morte de espécies
no mundo todo e também de contaminação
do oceano hoje existem ilhas de lixo
espalhadas pelo mundo pela fifa marta
exposição de resíduo acabam criando
ilhas de lixo em todo o planeta e
revisão é um desses resíduos
uma empresa americana conseguiu
transformar essas redes em tapetes e
carpetes carpete kentish town pisando
aqui só que ao invés de vender carpete
eles alugam carpete
então quer dizer eles transformaram um
projeto eles é uma empresa tradicional
de carpete que vende um carpete e que o
seu que que estar todo que teve essa
indefinição
fedor é assim eu não posso deixar meu
legado vendendo tradicionalmente como
outras empresas vivem ea e transformou o
negócio dele
hoje quase 95 por cento do que eles
produzem são resultado de reciclagem dos
carpetes que já vendeu no mercado e aí
eles alugam carpete ou seja a gente não
compraria mais carpete a gente
simplesmente aluga estrago e vem aqui
repõe e assim fica transformou um
produto em serviço
outra ideia mulher brasileira inclusive
a gente não compra mais água mais filtro
na acaba alugando água o que interessa
de fato é
é o filtro ou água gelada filtrada com
segurança na sua casa e aí espécie um
exemplo simples mas um exemplo que faz
repensar a forma de fazer produto
agora esse produto não é mais nosso ele
é alugado ser alugado o fabricante
precisa pensar um produto que dure mais
porque a manutenção fica por conta dele
conseqüentemente têm produtos que vão
durar mais pra quanto menos manutenção
melhor para o negócio dele e outra coisa
que consegue conversar diretamente com o
cliente que antigamente conversava
através do varejo que então é uma
mudança que esse exemplo brasileiro traz
que começa a acontecer pelo mundo e vou
passar um pequeno vídeo agora de um
projeto que a gente teve envolvido de
chrome circular e eu já retorna ea gente
prefere viver um cheiro de sujeira ou
vivendo um ventinho
eu voto rui chegou a falar e disse que
tinha uma surpresa pra gente foi uma
coisa muito emocionais tinha que trazer
o primeiro só embalagem do suco tang que
eu tinha esse claro a gente a ter 9 11
nestas aulas e que ia fazer os
instrumentos e aprendendo a tocar
no começo o projeto de ir pra mim ela
guardar umas coisas para levar a mãe não
se entende que esse clã você quer deixar
este mundo mais poluído do que já tem
dia que ela ia jogar onde rosa fora eu
não joga na dificuldade pra ensinar esse
projeto pra mim foi muito boa porque
percebi que esse clã também dá pra fazer
música é uma coisa que vou levar para
minha vida roda não tem mim fala vai
ficar é bom pra todos e reciclagem
menino já estaria mesmo se jogar lixo na
rua e filmes e onde está sujo e vamos
aproveitá lá quem paquete gil tiveram 50
segundos claro quem acha que o show eu
faço parte desse esquadrão
esse é um projeto um dos pratos quentes
envolvidos que o desafio era transformar
a embalagem que não tinha uma solução de
reciclagem até o momento com bagagem
tripla camada em alguma coisa que
pudesse voltar pra escola e deixar um
legado
foram 50 anos 50 e 100 escolas públicas
brasileiras 100 mil pessoas envolvidas
cooperativa de catadores coletando as
embalagens as crianças engajado no
processo de reciclagem a retornar e
voltar como resultado disso foram mais
de 50 mil instrumentos musicais e
distribuído nas escolas públicas com
tudo isso é uma falta é feita da
embalagem coletada é e aí com isso essas
escolas tiveram e têm ainda hoje aulas
de música para tentar usando os
instrumentos que eles ajudaram a
construir
então acho que esse é um resumo de como
ele acredita que a coisa pode acontecer
e obviamente que o dono da empresa dona
da marca na verdade conseguiu entender
quando critico é aquela embalagem para
ser reciclado pós-consumo isso está
gerando várias conversas internas para
repensar esse modelo e ver como
facilitar isso pouso do produto dela e
não só vender produto e chegar a isso no
consumidor
mas como repensar isso na hora de
produzir
a então isso é um exemplo do que a gente
vive e em que nosso dia a dia lá uma
gincana cada dia vi um desafio desse pra
gente tentar resolver é e o que que é
voltando pouco que a menina só a minha
gestão empreendedora o que me inspira e
inspiração pessoas
eu acredito demais que pode fazer uma
revolução eu tenho certeza que tudo pode
melhorar essa otimista por natureza e
quando ele se junta para o bem quando se
junta para transformar isso é real então
algumas pessoas que influenciam seus
clientes que vão nossas cooperativas de
catadores trabalha com mais de 2 mil
cooperados é todos os meses aí sim 12
cidades isso no brasil é tentando
transformar um pouco e engajados e que
são clientes visitando cooperativa de
catadores
nós temos bons parceiros trabalha com
algumas ongs o teto é uma delas
onde a gente entregou uma casa feita com
base em reciclada por uma família que
vivia num barraco totalmente destruído
minha família é obviamente nem foi a
chuva de granizo que pingo d'água depois
da meia noite nas mais um é é cada vez
maior no amor que está em coraçãozinho
está aí ea dona da casa que a minha
filhota
e essas pessoas que me inspiram mais uma
foto com seu pai coruja se quiser ter
mais um monte no celular aqui pra quem
quiser ver e o que a mesma mensagem é
que eu acredito acho que se a gente tem
que amar a vida curtir porque quando
você viu já passou que agradecer demais
obrigado por todo mundo